if you were starting an institution now
as a startup that you wanted to last for
hundreds of years what are some of the
that one of the ways that that you would
put into place now if you are an
organization that is at its first
generational change like long now is
what would you do in that case and if
you were an organization that let's say
was five generations in but was starting
to find the world was changing around
you and you were becoming less relevant
what would you do in that case
and the reason I'm framing it this way
is well we want to create this new
discipline of long lived institutions
and I very much feel as though long now
is the first client of this new
consultancy I also want this I want us
to be the that central place that people
come to for all kinds of lessons so
while the we mentioned this at lunch the
lessons that that that Peter brought up
about DuPont that's not a long now
lesson like we can't that's not a
portable for us and the portability of a
lot of these concepts is really
important so that you know the the other
thing that came up at lunch is just
because you know you're the they're the
family confectioner family-run
confectioner of the the Emperor of Japan
that's that's a very that's a very non
portable piece of advice for how to be a
long-lived institution right and but the
the piece of advice that's that that
Peter gave on you know selling at Peaks
to invest in in troughs is portable for
a whole set of organizations maybe not
us but what we want to do is and
especially in the breakout groups is
start to identify what are those things
that are portable and not portable and
what and where do they fit in different
types of cultural organizations and and
or companies and governments so with
that so I'm gonna demonstrate the thing
from the last session about lived
experience creating college since I'm
not speaking from in contrast to many of
the incredible talks we've heard from
people have very deep ex
forty's I have I think what has kind of
turned out to be a lifelong interest and
passion in this question of how you deal
especially with the thing you said if
again the sort of most dangerous moment
of the first generational transition
my mother's family owned a newspaper in
a small city in Virginia that did not
survive that transition and I was about
13 or 14 years old when that happened
and so later I was very sorry that they
had not managed to make that transition
but I've now probably worked with maybe
150 organizations served on about 20
boards read a lot of the literature and
for some strange reason in the last 10
years have done a number of deep
engagements with organizations trying to
deal with this kind of transition and so
this question of how you get how you set
up the conditions that are in fact
portable is really of interest to me and
so Zander asked me to just jot a few
things down and so again very different
from what we've heard so far far I want
to take us into these next sessions to
apply what we've learned and just give
you a few of the things that that that
come to me and provoke your own your
your own reflections I think that one of
the specializations that I've had is
I've done a lot of work with
philanthropic foundations and so some
I'm gonna tell you a number of stories
some of them have to do with these
institutions that actually many of them
have been set up to operate in
perpetuity and so I've seen a lot of
cases of that done bad mostly badly some
well and and I think it's a very
interesting question at this particular
moment where we have a lot of new energy
and new effort to solve the world's
problems in new ways by organizations
that are still founder led either
nonprofits or businesses and for the
nonprofit's what's really interesting
is that the nine figure gifts the big
gifts only go to institutions that have
proven they can survive
intergenerational transition think about
it you would not give money yourself to
an institution that was still found or
led above a hundred million dollars or
you know just some fill in job you they
go to hospitals they go to you know
sleeve a still go to universities
hospitals museums you know with very few
exceptions they all go to institutions
where people know these people will
understand long lived institution so
it's a non-trivial problem to solve for
for newer institutions so here's a
little map that I made I'm gonna walk
you through kind of three principles
that I came up with or through three
what I'm calling touchstones because
they're not really criteria or
guidelines that are what long term what
institutions required to have the
ability to pass between a monk between
and among multiple generations and the
first thing is what I'm going to call
the founding DNA and somebody told me
this recently maybe one of you know
where this came from
they couldn't remember who said it if a
ship is crossing the ocean who is in
charge not the captain the designer of
the ship which I just love and I think
there is something here that I've seen
over and over again especially in older
institutions that are now not in the
first generational transition but in the
second or third what was the enduring
guidance and what assets were created
that are worth stewarding right so and
and because because the implication of
having a long term institution is it
matters that it lasts and there's some
kind of anchor that that the founding
generation leaves behind it so the trick
seems to be so if you go down there has
to be some kind of purpose some purpose
that matters that that it goes on there
has to be
some kind of embedded in explicit values
that give guidance and there's some sort
of institutional design and norms and
the trick seems to be enough structure
so that there's not free-floating chaos
as then as it passes but not too much
right so so on the you know the
Rockefeller Foundation which was one of
the original now independent private
foundations founded in 1913 John D
Rockefellers mission to the Rockler
foundation was basically to benefit
humanity doesn't get any broader than
that but I got to be in the room when
the head of the Rockefeller archives put
together a presentation for the family
which at that point included David
Rockefeller who was almost as old as the
foundation he was 98 years old he's
since died but the family was assembled
in the room and the head of the
Rockefeller archives gave a presentation
to say thank you from humanity here's
what the Rockefeller Foundation made
happen over the last hundred years
who knew that three members of the
Rockefeller Foundation staff died trying
to figure out how to how to deal with
yellow fever you know it was like they
hired two postdoc historians to like
figure out what happened it's an
extraordinary set of things that
happened because john d rockefeller
didn't say we're going to work on the
future of this place in this area and
that was it it was like each generation
had to reinvent it and and say what is
it that humanity needs now it was an
incredible gift on the other hand these
kind of broad purposes that can be
really reinvented now that wasn't
actually I can say cuz the rock floor
foundation was one of my clients for a
couple years that was almost too broad
and so what happened is they
distinguished themselves in agriculture
and science and other things over the
years so actually they had you know some
history that helped inform them what to
do to interpret what that meant on the
other hand on institutional and design
and norms a foundation that's now close
to a hundred years old
foundation that that shall go unnamed at
this moment operates with a very
specific charter that its board must
meet once a month now just think about
that that is so unbelievably stupid
really really really made sense in the
town that that thing was founded in in
the 1920s I think where the people would
come for lunch once a month and have
their meeting now the people in this
global foundation either get ready for a
board meeting have a board meeting or
follow up from a board meeting it's
unbelievable I once asked the president
Foundation how much time he spent
dealing with his Board of the answer was
80% right really not smart right so
these things who designs the ship you
know really does matter so without some
sort of purpose and clarity about the
purpose it'll falter but with too much
it it's it's some and this I think this
is too much of these things it's it's a
problem and so what's that sweet spot is
really key the the second thing and this
is this is harder and more complex is
the clarity on who is we so if I walk
you through this who selects the leaders
and who is empowered to make decisions
in trade-offs and there's a flavor of
this for private nonprofit I mean
private for-profit and there's a favor
for a non-profit public this is often
equivalent governance and ownership and
the answer that question is often
equivalent to ownership the control sits
in ownership of course that's more
complicated in a public publicly held
business in a non-profit it so it's its
governance is everything who owns long
now who's responsible for it who you
know carries you know that's a really
complex question and I'm going to
suggest you some some how critically
important it is for a community to
actually feel that it owns a not the
great nonprofits I know the ones that
don't have big endowments like
foundations are held and owned by a
community in which there is then a guy
structure that that has to have the
decision-making authority the if you are
going to continue to adapt and sometimes
have to make really hard trade-offs
somebody has to be empowered to do that
which is actually why I am skeptical
that without without extremely
well-designed understood and governance
structures that any market-based
for-profit business at scale can survive
in the long term so just a just think
for a second about the New York Times as
an institution so New York Times was
founded in 1851 the modern company was
formed in 1896 when it was bought by
Adolph Ochs and and and consolidated
maybe with some other papers he owned it
was privately held until 1969 when it
went public it adopted a dual stock
structure so that the family controlled
it still controlled it which now a
number of the tech companies the big
tech companies Google and Facebook have
borrowed that same structure so that the
founders actually control the company
you can say what whether that's a good
thing or not in in those cases but the
sixth generation family member to be in
charge of the company the 38 year old AG
Salzburg er just took over the New York
Times that's kind of astonishing that
and it's a you know so the ownership and
governance were designed to empower
certain people to be in place to make
the trade-offs right because the
trade-off between firing reporters and
upping the near-term profit or keeping
the deeper content and building for the
long term is a is you have to be
empowered to make that decision and I
think mostly in their by the rules of
the game then public markets today it's
very difficult not always but but it is
is difficult the worst one of the worst
situations I would say though
just because it's over on the on the
side of number one of the worst ones
I've ever seen was a fifth-generation
same amount of time family foundation of
some scale that was one of the most
dysfunctional situations I have ever
seen you know so just because it's you
know because it was very poorly designed
in the governance structure for how the
family would control it how they would
bring in some fresh energy it was it was
a you know just horrible horrible
situation so this one this issue of who
is we who gets to decide and and how
that is navigated is a really key in my
experience question and then the final
thing is the resilient resource model
and and and here I mean in Maslow's
hierarchy if you can't survive I mean
that's the fundamental thing you talked
about this in terms of business models
needing to be reinvented the there is a
survival sustainability imperative and
an ability and and and the need to
protect and adapt that therefore back to
the design governance the ownership and
their multiple ways this can happen cap
you know capital can be available in
family and business context they're
gonna be endowments there can be ongoing
customers there can be members and they
could be ongoing philanthropic giving
but there's got to be the you know the
the refreshing way of getting resources
in and the creativity to keep adapting I
mean just a few years ago look like the
New York Times it might not make it
right so that was entirely business
model question and it's still might not
you know it's a these are all three of
these things have got to be in place an
aspiring purpose you know guidance from
the fountain in in in some way that that
that goat that gets passed through a
sense of who is we and where the power
and control sets Anna and a resource
model now the the I just want to tell
you you know and and what I would say is
that too often mission driven
organizations don't pay enough skilled
attention to the
resource model and too often businesses
pay overlooked the other two right and
in my experience right so every
organization I've ever seen it doesn't
matter if it's nonprofit or business has
to deal with its mission and with its
resource model it just looks different
whether it's a business or a non-profit
and so the you know and one of the
reasons that for long-term survivability
endowments are so critic an be so
critical is that it makes it so fear of
survival is not tantamount in moments of
stress right so that you so that when
the trade-offs get made you don't
destroy the the underlying you have to
destroy the underlying purpose now two
quick stories to just illustrate this
model that are hugely different one to
two of my really favorite stories one of
us from from tightly held in a family
situation over almost two hundred years
one in in a total pioneering global
institution so on the on this the first
one is the private one it just so
happened that my college roommate was a
member of the Forbes family the Forbes
family the great great New England
patrician family
John Murray Forbes in the 1840s 1850s I
couldn't figure out exactly when bought
a little island called Michonne and
Nashawn is off the coast of Cape Cod
seven miles long just you can see can
see Martha's Vineyard from it and this
has been continuously in the family
since the 1850s they are now I believe
in the in the sixth generation the and
here the asset that they own is the land
right so they have this land it is the
most pristine land in the Northeast it's
studied by ever they've allowed no
chemicals on the island there's rules
about
there are no cars there's no you have
rules about the trash you drag your own
suitcase to the house that you're
staying in they had a three year long
discussion about whether it allowed
bicycles you know it's a it's this is an
extraordinary thing right and because it
has this DNA right so the land to
preserve the land and with values of not
materialistic right and so it has it has
the mission to preserve the land it has
the values and then he didn't have to
set up any mechanism when he further who
is we he had six children to who was we
was very clear but then once the six
children went along they realized oh
we have to design a governance
structure so they did and this is my
favorite part of the story over time so
the trustees are elected for life they
have seven of them anybody in the family
they're now almost a thousand people in
the family anybody in the family can pay
a thousand dollars a year and be a
member of which allows them to go to the
island or and to elect the trustees but
they figured out over time that of the
seven trustees two of them must be
in-laws so that they get fresh air into
the system right and and then on the
resource question he endowed it he left
money for the maintenance of the island
it's now twenty million dollars and they
have all kinds of rules to get more
money and my college roommate Carlisle
says that she thinks it's going to make
it two hundred years it's gonna make it
through her lifetime she's not sure
it'll make it much longer
and but but it will become a public
trust it will not ever become anything
else right yeah there's only I think now
there's only about a third of the family
really cares it's going to be leadership
and enough money to maintain it and it's
it's it's it's an awfully big
responsibility right and so it'll just
be if are there enough family members
who have the will to to to keep it going
and we
there'd be the resources to keep
maintaining the the island I believe is
what she is what she thinks yeah yeah
and so but I think it's a I think there
are a number of things in that story
about something worth preserving the
values the very skillful governance
structure and the assets to maintain it
that our that our that our part of this
this little system that I that I credit
here and then the other will be quite
familiar to everybody but it's worth
just saying how extraordinary is which
is Wikimedia the Wikimedia Foundation is
only 50 just over 15 years old was
founded in 2003 and they are actually I
would think you'd have to bet at this
point that they've done virtually
everything right to become a long-term
institution hugely successful thoughtful
they actually I was earlier this week
with the woman who is executive director
of Wikimedia she said they call it
regenerative governance they are they
really are trying to in reinvent etre a
village system but for the globe right
so on the assets DNA the purpose is a
world in which every single human being
can freely share in the sum of all
knowledge free knowledge for all
inspiring vision an enduring purpose and
then they've spent a lot of energy
designing the infrastructure of the who
is we right so we really incredible
they're 250,000 active volunteers they
have three kinds of affiliates they have
300 staff that maintain the
infrastructure they have 10 board
members half of whom were elected by the
community they just finished a global
interactive participatory strategy
exercise that set the direction to 2030
that claim that said we see ourselves as
a movement rooted in values that have
but it has all of these elaborate
structures in place first of all to to
clarify who is we it's really the
250,000 people who are really part of
the community volunteer how they make
decision
how they select the leaders and this
broad ownership of a community that
really feels it owns it right so that
it's not about who the executive
director is or who the board is but it's
broadly owned and it's owned and held
together by the very top right by the
purpose and the values and the and the
design of it right and now they've now
they've also expanded their resource
model so they have started an endowment
it's already over a hundred million
dollars I only started in 2016 and they
are actively they have a pretty big
fundraising department they're raising
money all the time they raise money from
people who use and if you use it you've
seen the you know and they course have
volunteer labor that's the fuel that the
resource model is volunteer labor now
the verdict will be out we'd have to be
back here in a hundred years to ask did
it did it work but I would guess Mike my
guess would be that that that's a that
is going to work and so those are you
know those are two that I think are very
interesting different designs and long
now will be somewhere in between those
two you know yeah there are so many case
studies I mean I'm looking at my
different lawrence and my friend Marty
you guys have more experience than I do
with or I'm sure you can tell lots of
these tales too you know and I just this
I'm sure this is I just made this up but
to come to here you know I mean out of
my own experience but I would just say I
really think you have to have all three
of these things and most most situations
I've been in that involves
intergenerational succession actually
falter on the middle one as as much as
the others but I I just have a couple
more things to say and then I'll finish
up Stewart
yeah I don't know cuz I don't I don't
know either of the stories I just told
you intimately but he has a of the ten
seats on the board of directors he has
one right so they've they've somehow
carved a role out for him that it
matters to him that you know they've
already had I think they're on their
either second or third executive
director right so they've already done
transitions and leadership and they've
they've had some controversy like the
board didn't like one of the people that
was seated by the vote and they tried to
throw that person out and then people
elected that person again and so I don't
know what yeah I'm sure and and I'm sure
it's not stable they have to keep
adapting it that's why the executive
director calls it regenerative
Governance you know I mean so so but
you're but in that case the reason I'm
actually optimistic about them is this
is that they're held so that's such an
inspiring purpose and it's held by such
a large community mm-hmm yeah yeah so
let me just say what I think this adds
up to for a second and then we can talk
this really is about trying to generate
these converse as you get you these are
these are I was scribbling notes all day
long you know from the different the
different things and so it it seems to
me that what we're talking about is is
creating structures that that deliver
intangible value of trust and belief so
today we know one of the biggest
problems we have is the lack of trust in
institutions so somehow the combination
of these things managed well and wisely
with a great purpose gives people a
sense of this old fashioned word which I
love which is stewardship you know the
careful and responsible management of
something entrusted to one's care which
again implies that there's an asset
worth preserving the world's knowledge a
pristine people piece of land an
institution vital to American democracy
in terms of newspapers
you know so there's something that's
been entrusted to you in your generation
you are standing in a river there are
people behind you and people are coming
after you and your job is to fulfill
your responsibilities and your
generation of caring for this thing
right that that is the the intangible
you know trust belief responsibility and
but that in order to create that
requires these tangibles these tangibles
these these these kind of you know you
can call it a design you could call it a
technology you know it's it's a it's a
social technology of ownership of
governance of of how organizations work
of you know of the of the resource model
you know and and those two things that
but without those tangibles that support
and strengthen the intangibles you you
you know the Angels just they won't
survive they may be inspiring for a
moment in a movement and then they go
away so so the a couple of questions
that occur to me I'm think it's an
interesting question about the scale for
purpose it's not an accident it seems
perfectly sensible to me that 90% of the
things you looked at were under 300
people right there's something about the
the belief the belonging the community
the the family like the the asset in the
case of the family business is the
business to pass through the generations
and the family the that keeps the family
together the the coherence but but look
at Wikimedia you know it's actually the
right scale for what it's attempting to
do it's it has a billion unique accesses
each month Wikimedia so so what is the
right scale and I do actually I will
raise I will raise the question of
whether a business operated at scale
without some mitigating ownership or
control system can survive in the long
term
but but no in the rules of the market as
we currently have it right that there's
a reason that there's not very many and
there's a reason that it's going down
and so it and then I think there's the
how the span of control is designed to
match the mission so if it's a tightly
controlled little island seven people is
fine but if it's the world's knowledge
and you designed a system of seven
people to control it it would blow up
instantly right so there's something
about about the relationship between the
who's the community who owns it and how
the control and decision-making is
designed that is critical and and and
and then I and then the thing that I
have observed in my life is the
absolutely critical moment is how trade
offs are managed so at a at a moment of
crisis or a moment of transition or a
moment of decision or a moment of
adaptation who gets to manage the trade
offs and how those trade offs are
managed against always conflicting and
competing purposes because every
institution has competing of conflicting
purposes how trade offs are managed I I
would hypothesize is maybe V key factor
for how whether long to other
institutions succeed in the long term
so I mean I have some from my own life
that are private and I can't share but I
think that most obvious one is the New
York Times right so so at multiple if
you go back and look at the history of
that newspaper all the way back into the
1960s almost went our business in the
1960s and they that's when they they
reinvented their sections and how all
the ways they did things back in the
1960s when Abe Rosenthal was the exec
you
editor but but it's a you know they they
have made they have had to do layoffs
they have cut their they had to cut
their budget when they went after the
downturn some of you in this room we
were together in many cases in the mid
to late 90s trying to work with
newspapers on how they could survive and
it was very clear what was going to
happen it was just unclear how fast it
would happen and it was very hard they
were making a lot of money and it was
very hard to convince people to do the
things they needed to do and then the
dot-com crash came and they all went I
told you so you know it's all this
digital stuff is and then boom the
depression recession hit and you know
half the reporters in America have lost
their job in the last ten years
all there are cities in America that
have no news no they're called news
deserts now you know local news is
absolutely decimated and the New York
Times had came to a number of junctures
Stewart that other newspaper companies
made the call a different way there are
almost no family controlled newspapers
anymore where they could either cut 200
reporters and you know and keep their
profit margins up or not and the souls
burger family repeatedly because they
control the stock they control the board
did not decimate the the journalism of
the New York Times and that's a that's
managing for the mission in the long
term versus a profitability now we know
there's the most famous large company in
the world right now one of them Amazon
has repeatedly insisted on doing that
and and gotten it so far it's worked but
it's a you know managing for the long
term market share not the short term
profitability the in terms of the way
Amazon has constantly you know had lower
made lower money in the short term
invested it and instead of building you
know in order to build for the long term
but I I think it's a it's a it's a
managing that trade-off between what we
need to do for now versus what we're
trying to do for other longer purposes
rather than in a business case so so
let's say let's take a non profit I'm
just going to make something up let's
take a non profit that has you know
relies on philanthropy and you know
doesn't have a very diverse business
model and the classic the classic thing
that happens is a funder comes in and
says here's a very large sum of money to
do this thing that I want done and it
doesn't happen to be the thing that you
want to do we've all seen that and the
desperate nonprofit that has no
endowment no ability to manage that
trade-off well has to say thank you very
much and I'll take the money right but
if the institution has a diverse
resource model the strength and will and
clarity about its purpose and its
decision-making to say no we don't have
to take that money we can in fact say
thank you very much but we have this
this thing that we're set to do right
that would be the way it sometimes plays
out in in and so you know that latter
that the the the bad version of that has
weakened or killed a number of you know
more public interests kinds of
organizations over time but anyway yeah
yes yes
yeah yes well that all of these things
play out in very complex ways and and
none of there's not I I was just making
sewers asking the I just think that that
leadership systems actually that I
believe in not just leaders that have
the ability to make the right decision
to manage trade-offs as they're needed
but to make decisions with with the
whole in mind that that's just um
setting that up and having that work
well over time it's just not easy no
it's it's but but I think for long-term
institutions I know that endowments are
not fashionable these days they're hard
to raise money for there's a whole lot
of people who say you know foundations
philanthropic foundations should not be
set up in perpetuity I think there's a
really strong argument about those
things and I think for long-term
institutions like long now
the existence of at least some endowment
not total dependence on an endowment but
some endowment allows you it's part of
the resilience I mean if I were smart
enough I could translate from some of
Eric's unbelievably gorgeous pictures
into how this would would work because I
think there's something about additional
resilience and ability to adapt and
withstand shocks that that some capital
pool and businesses often have capital
pools if if nonprofits don't have an
endowment they usually don't have
capital pools because if they have a lot
of money on their books people say why
should we fund you have plenty of money
you know when they go to ask for money
unless they're clever and put it off in
a supporting organization so we we were
gonna have to break up into a group
thank you by the way
[Applause]
you
[Music]